hey guys hello Mr Bridges
congratulations Rachel Stern from
entertainment
hi in your speech tonight you you uh
thanked your dad today is his birthday
and you thanked him for kind of
introducing you to the acting world how
special is it to share this honor with
him tonight oh man it really meant a lot
hopefully what do you think Dad I got
your cufflinks
thank you Dad it meant so much to me you
know it was uh the fact that it was his
birthday
it's kind of surreal yeah and also
another gentleman you shared this honor
with tonight was Mr Goodman who stepped
in last minute to help you accept this
award you know you guys start in 25
years ago in The Big Lebowski so are we
getting that sequel you've kind of
spoken about wanting to do it oh well
it's all set up you know mod you know
she's impregnated man
[Music]
I don't know you gotta talk to the
brothers about it I kind of doubt it
you've been through so much how surreal
does this honor mean tonight to be
standing here today with this Lifetime
Achievement Award oh it feels really
terrific
uh
I'm a little upset for a couple of
reasons you know you I'm gut checking
you know running dailies in my mind of
this thing I said and what I wanted to
say up there
you know I I went I was sick for two
years with cancer and covet and when I
talked about my family Sue and my
daughters
I wanted to you know
talk about their support during that
time you know I didn't think I was going
to make it at all you know let alone
going back to work but because they
supported me so beautifully I was able
to go back and finish the old man this
season you know we were stopped in the
middle of the season
it was very surreal it was like we had a
two-year long weekend you know and then
we came back to work
and uh you know I'd say to the you know
Amy brennaman and Lithgow you know I'd
say I had the weirdest dream guys I was
in the hospital you know couldn't
believe it but uh
their support during those times and
also the old man you know doing that
show was uh it's terrific and I'm so
happy that we're gonna do another season
starting up in March well we're so happy
you're still with us congratulations
Larry Jeff Larry from Fox News digital
congratulations thank you man what has
been your favorite role that you played
no gotta say that corny thing that the
actors say about their kids you know
it's like who's your favorite kid yeah
each each one even the ones that don't
come off so well aren't as successful
wonderful experience and like I said up
there tonight they're like little
lifetimes you know you intense jamming
with all these wonderful creative people
it's it's amazing is there a bucket list
role that you would like to play no no I
never I never did that
uh
you ever thought of it that way too much
uh
um there's a couple of things that are
in the in the in the you know the fire
there but uh nothing definite thank you
so much all right thanks a lot Jeff
thank you guys yeah yeah could you
record one memory of your first award
and the first time you read a critic
about you say again one more time the
first time you got an award and the
first time you got a critic about you
the last part in the first time I did
what about me yeah
it did
I don't know I can't
well I remember the first time I got an
award
was for The Last Picture Show
and uh
these award Seasons you know there
should be a special award for the
publicist you know because now if every
you know it's like but back in those
days I remember being just a kid you
know 19 years old getting a call at you
know five o'clock in the morning or
something said yeah you've been
nominated I said what you know
and uh does that answer your question I
didn't see the entire the last part of
your question the first time you read a
critic about you oh a critic about me
critique about me
gee I can't I can't think of one I can't
I can't think of one of those the first
time just nothing pops into my head but
it wasn't bad then what's that it wasn't
bad I don't think it was a bad one I
don't know I don't read those if it
starts to you know get better look
Turn the Page
all right thanks a lot guys